Hey, yo, son, these contracts is mad thick, son.
I ain't finna sit here and read all this shit.
You better off tellin ****** what you want.
Give me five years of your life.
Atención, por favor
Yeah, that **** better be hard.
You just wrote this **** right now.
Yeah, son.
What you thought I was doing on the
roof the whole time?
Not supposed to go on the roof.
If he keeps writing like this, he can climb
to the top of the Empire State Building.
Yo, this ****. Is ***** hard, son.
King Kong ******
Hey, yo.
It's about **** time.
It's about ****** time, yo. I was waiting for this.
Hey, what's this beast?
This ain't the shit we spit.
It's that Wu-Tang shit. Yeah.
This **** gonna tear the club up.
Yo, son. I ain't ever heard no
**** like this before, yo.
I ain't never heard no **** like this.
Went to the movies and dipped off like, two
days.
They was playing the whole dragon marathons.
Dragon fish. Dragon lords. The ****, the
dragon feather ****. The whole **** have me
spent on dragon. God need to chill out.
What you think?
I think. I think we're getting this pressed
up tomorrow.
Right? Yo.
Everybody, check this out. All right.
Needs a... needs a hook or something, you know
what I'm saying?
Oh, protect your neck ain't have no hook.
But this **** different. I'm feeling like this ****
actually needs that ****.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
What up?
I need a course. Yo, if you have another one
liners, play some some melodic **** for this.
You know what I'm saying?
Electra is owned by Warner Brothers.
Warner Brothers is a publicly traded company
All right. So, look, boom.
We still got Def Jam on the table, right?
Yeah. But, you know, they can also pull they
offer too. We have to make a decision.
Cash rules everything around me. Cream. Get
the money. Dollar. Dollar bills, y'all. Hey,
Think carefully, RZA. You don't want to play
yourself. Or maybe you already have.
Damn two hundred K down the gutter.
That ain't no short money, playa. Not at
all. You're only saying that cause I got no
strategy. No vision.
Too scared to play the game.
Checkmate.
All right.
You may have beat me. But did you really win?
**** sell out. Yo. Oh, ****.
Yo.
I don't really know how to play.
No.
Can you teach me? All right.
All right. So when you start a game, you
never want to show fear.
Ever. The way you start determines how you
finish. You want to step into your bravery,
Even if that means being scared. You got to
think about the future. We want Wu-Tang
to be forever.
You get it?
Think so.
What do I do next?
Yo, RZA what's up, man?
We just signed to Loud.
Wait, you just **** what?